if a human being lives the life where
they spend their time going around
social networks finding your content and
leaving something nasty about you that
you are not good looking that you are
stupid that you don't know what you're
talking about do not feel bad for
yourself feel bad for them
do you know how sad of a life it is to
take your time to seek out people on the
internet that you don't know and leave
nasty comments to make them feel bad
that person is in a very bad place when
I say feel bad for them I don't mean say
you and be mad at them I'm saying
have compassion and sympathy for them
that they are in a bad place in their
lives that they are spending their
valuable time to try to hurt your
feelings someone they probably don't
even know if we can get the world to
have more compassion for the people that
are nasty the world could be in a much
better place and more importantly that's
a big goal you'll be happier if you can
find compassion and empathy for people
that are dragging you down